okay well first of all thank you for
doing this with us it's so good to see
you yeah zu ether I know it's so good to
see you the last time I saw you was at
the Create cultivate event when people
could actually congregate I know and
here we are like in our homes in our
homes I know it how are you doing how's
the family doing with all of this you
know I have to say this is almost almost
two weeks so almost day 14 for me and
it's starting to get to me the first
week I was like yeah you know this is
great you know I'm at home like this is
awesome I'm chilling but then you know I
mean to be honest with you yesterday was
was a little even today it's a little
overwhelming for me I was meditating
because it's one way on how we've been
staying sane in the house and I just
started to cry I literally just started
bawling and that had never happened to
me before with like meditation and I
think it's because I I was focusing on
everyone else and not necessarily myself
I was focusing on how do I keep the kids
busy how I'm making dinner how do I keep
my husband busy Kairo just kind of
juggling everything increase pooling
online that I wasn't able to really tap
into my own feelings and what I was
going through or feeling about this
whole situation so you know we're doing
okay when you have those moments those
tearful moments those emotional moments
how do you kind of pull yourself out of
that and what's like the biggest trigger
do you think I think well first of all
to answer your question on how do I pull
myself out of that moment I have to give
a lot of credit to my husband because we
were meditating together and it's
something that we've been doing together
and we looked at each other and he was
like no it's gonna be okay we got this
you've got this this will all be over
you know we just don't know when but you
know know that everything will be okay
that's one of them
main things that helps me get out of
this is just the support for my husband
how's your sister doing I mean I know
that we're all sort of in a quarantine
right now are you able to see your
family through all of this that to be
honest with you has been the hardest
part of course I get to see my family my
husband and my children but not being
able to see I do about to cry sorry no
it's okay I wish I could like reach out
oh you're fine there's somebody inside a
Christian but not to be able to see my
dad my brothers and my sister has been
pretty hard because we're all very close
you know but um we've handled it very
well with um with FaceTime each other so
we've been faced living each other my
brother the other day you show me what
you made for dinner and it's like crazy
how we're getting excited about the
simple things like look what I made
dinner you know I'm constantly checking
up on his well-being like how are you do
moving emotionally especially with my
dad and my mom you know because they're
older and that's what I think it's just
so important to stay inside you know
what I mean like I always say Mike been
saying it's you know safer at home and
staying at home saves lives so but
anyway I'm I'm able to talk to my mom
and my dad on FaceTime we talk like
almost every day but my sister has well
been texting each other you know she's
doing well she's you know with her kids
but I believe that's been the hardest
you know just not being able to you know
your loved ones but we're gonna get to
this yeah it's it's all gonna be good so
sorry no you're okay I think we're all
kind of feeling that way and I asked I
think about all the people who live
alone and don't even have family to be
with and I think I know her freakin
thing about this and it's really
humanizing all of us and it's making us
realize we're all in this together ever
be your regular celebrity and add Leah
are like we're all going for 11 minutes
do you get together
yep